mélodie vous faites quoi dans la vie je
suis serveuse d'accord où ça un prêt 90
à petit-mars prénom nom alors vous vous
avez une proposition justement pour la
parité homme femme sur les salaires
alors 7
ça rejoint l'économie mais comme c'est
vrai qu'on en parlait avec man aramis
c'est une proposition qui nous intéresse
ici est qu'on a envie de proposer à nos
téléspectateurs donc raconté pas en fait
c'est surtout un complément de sur le la
hausse du smic en fait c'est déjà en
premier qu'il faut faire une
revalorisation des grilles salariales
sur les conventions collectives
nationales parce que la hausse du smic
concerne pas tout le monde est là
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on demande c'est dérisoire d'achat
pour tous les citoyens
donc ça c'est la première chose qui
était importante et surtout l'égalité
des salaires hommes femmes
alors c'est on va on va retenir ça là
parce que c'est très important l'égalité
donc les salaires hommes-femmes
alors quelle est la différence
aujourd'hui marlène schiappa eux
je crois que c'est une qualif gaby ya
plusieurs choses d'abord on est en
écarts de salaires entre les femmes et
les hommes 2,9 à 27% alors je suis à
veut dire que tous les ministres sont
payés paris oui parce que c'est des
salaires de grille est d'accord mais
néanmois actuellement en moyenne si vous
avez une femme et un homme qui exerce le
même métier mêmes compétences
il ya 9 % d'accord salaire en moins pour
la femme et au global
si on compte les arrêts de travail les
discriminations subies
on arrive à 27% beaucoup on a fait
quelque chose là dessus on a voté une
loi pour la transparence des écarts de
salaires à partir du 1er mars qui arrive
là toutes les grandes entreprises vont
devoir rendre public leur pourcentage
d'écart de salaire entre les femmes et
les hommes seriez vous allez devoir nous
dire si vous payez moins les
chroniqueurs que les chroniqueurs je
crois que les prix
je crois que les paye plus parce que je
les préfère chose vous avez dit quelque
chose super intéressant sur les
négociations des salles à moi je suis
frappé de voir que depuis le début du
mouvement autour des gilets jaunes et
des discussions pas beaucoup de pouvoir
d'achat de revalorisation des salaires
du smic etc
en fait on s'adresse rarement aux
partenaires sociaux est en fait bon jeu
par branches ce sont les partenaires
sociaux qui peuvent re négocier
justement le niveau de salaire par
domaine d'activité tout ne dépend pas de
l'état je sais qu'on attend beaucoup
d'états et c'est normal car au de l'état
de faire beaucoup c'est notre âme et on
est là pour ça non en plus il ya aussi
les partenaires sociaux via les
employeurs il ya les syndicats il faut
les interpeller il faut dire aux syndics
s'engager encore davantage sur l'égalité
femmes-hommes que ça n'ait fait
actuellement alors marlène schiappa
régis juste s côte et mélodie je crois
que tu allais partir dans un rap la
[Rires]
truck qui serait je pense important
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises se
font quand même pas mal de bénéfices
sans leur distribuer aux salariés il
pourrait être voté une loi qui dit que
appartement une entreprise fait un gros
bénéfices ce soit obligatoire de
renégocier des grilles de salaires pour
les salariés
à l'instant t et que ce soit distribuée
en tant que prime pour les salariés mais
d'une façon obligatoire par une loi
d'accord alors mélodies et eu beaucoup
de choses forcément sèchement va on va
refaire ce genre de trucs donc ça on va
le mettre où on est d'accord noval m on
va le mettre de côté
moi je voudrais juste qu'on retienne pas
ce qu'on va faire 506 millions l'égalité
obligatoire des salaires femmes à poil à
expliquer parce que ça c'est dans la loi
depuis la rentrée s'est pas appliqué
voilà nour encore que les pénalités
là je crois que ça remet en course et
s'est invitée mais elles sont déjà
victimes de la pauvreté en france ce
sont des femmes
absolument être présent il ya des femmes
seules sont les femmes on trouve
beaucoup voilà alors ou bien victimes
on va voir d'abord le la proposition d'
avons un conte avait eu bien sûr
l'égalité obligatoire des salaires entre
les hommes et les femmes 90 m pour 90 on
espère mais en fait l'égalité quand vous
l'aviez d'égalité obligatoires s'est
aussi renforcée donc les pénalités parce
que pour que on arrive à cette égalité
totale